[Music]
it's alright
this week we've got squeaky breathing
private elevator and joint apology
take it away tip mm-hmm so for our first
story there was a 8 year old boy in
Argentina
that's accidentally swallowed a party
hooter so they're like oh that that's
called hooter I mean that's what they're
calling it in this article I thought
hooter was titty well if our folks in
the UK like I guess maybe UK that's what
they call it like English people it
sounds fine to a party hooter pot to
heat up like that kid got it stuck in
his throat what I ate he ate
that's a good joke I've seen it in
cartoons that's [ __ ] cute eight year
old why's he look like baby Nadeem and
she's like yeah so he had this stuck in
his throat oh that makes sense
wait does that go inside that yeah
that's what makes the noise I didn't so
he will energy that's probably what
happened he might have inhaled her they
don't really explain how I got caught
that think he looks like it's backwards
you know my dumbass thought that he
swallowed the whole thing yeah any when
he opened his mouth it was gonna come
out like a snake like but then I'll
surprised that he wasn't even choking
because I'll see ya luckily he's okay
and it was just like now we can laugh at
their because he wasn't seriously hurt
dude he just keep it in there probably
yeah you probably can't eat food no more
what kind of [ __ ] hands are those
dude look at something oh it's a it's
[Laughter]
again like it looked like some like when
you went into the ocean and your hands
got all [ __ ] up and at the same time
there's a lot of calluses like in your
palm I love no glasses job
he sent oh [ __ ] here he is with his mom
what country is this you know he looks
like they've had like a lot of people
asked him to do because he's so over it
I think again I mean you could be
looking again he's [ __ ] over it
already
look look at the second one you think
he's like I don't want to we stop it
already I would love to hear him jog a
mile
[Laughter]
[Applause]
luckily though that just sounds like the
freaking bathroom scene in psycho aren't
you trying to compare this because I was
just thinking I was like if he was
Barney but I don't like oh my gosh that
just reminds you a psycho cuz it goes
like yeah it sounds like those um you
know those kids shoes those sandals be
sandals yeah that line up yeah yeah the
door boy went viral I had like six point
six million views that's a viral
material for sure
did you put ads on that video that would
have sent it to all of you guys for sure
I know
all right bye our next story this man in
China illegally set up his own elevator
his own private elevator sounds about
right
yeah and he did this because he was
tired of his son-in-law complaining that
every time he goes visit him cuz he this
this man he lives on the sixth floor out
of seven floors his son-in-law kept
complaining that he kept getting tired
and wind it out every time he had to
climb up the six life of stairs the
son-in-law is complaining about himself
getting tired exactly okay but they
don't have an elevator on this thing it
could maybe it's in rural China so the
younger guys complaining to an older man
that gets tired going up okay yeah so
here's the illegal elevator it looks
really nice they're saying it's the
world's dumbest elevator ever because it
only goes from the first of 206 so this
fixed floor and that's it
how much do you have to pay for that I
know I wanted to know the thing down I
mean it makes sense he's not doing it
for other people it's just for a
son-in-law but he still needs to get
like permission from the building so he
didn't you just went ahead and did it on
his own you kinda remind me of your mom
okay she just does oh yeah yeah yeah I
think your mom would do that if you go I
don't want to come over it's too high oh
yeah there's the Sun and good health
they don't mention that that's a dumbass
request I feel like for a younger person
I don't think he was requesting and
you're just complaining like
I'm just so tired yeah but why is it
complaining so much
that's just how they're reporting it
this man was just sick and tired of
hearing his son-in-law complain he's
like you know what I'm just he must be
saying it a lot for him to go [ __ ] I
must fork out all this money to build
elevator are they rich and these are
rich Chinese don't mention that well
yeah I wonder how much it cost to do
that it looks really expensive like that
they're just saying this dumbass
elevator ever but the elevator looks
like it's just a basket metal basket
that goes up and it's surrounded by
glass pretty much yeah
yeah it doesn't look like a full-on
elevator like the way we have I wonder
if anyone ever walked into is it trying
to get did go to the second or third
floor no those are just the doors right
go the other picture it just looks like
a [ __ ] basket oh that's to go out
into this oh I thought that went up and
down no it's little bookshelf that way
what is that why does that [ __ ] all
weathered up in the middle like did they
you know how like when someone rubs it
too many times here yeah I think it's
that blue plastic for the heel oh yeah
ages never take the covering off so they
just wore through the plastic that's
actually worse for the thing and it
doesn't really protect it actually
scratches it more if you keep it on or
does it I don't know I mean all Asians
like they put saran wrap on the remote
control I go that's why is that I don't
know I just dad there's more dust and
oil and dirt the dust scratches actually
is this son-in-law happy pic good
question is he satisfied cuz like now he
visits me every day what if he just
doesn't want to [ __ ] go that's why
he's talking all that [ __ ] [ __ ] no now
he's like I could kind of relate a
little bit cuz my grandparents when I
first started visiting them when I was
like a little kid I think like three or
four they lived in a building that
didn't have an elevator to cousin they
were in Asia they started building tall
buildings even before they really had
elevators so I think they lived on like
either fourth or fifth floor and I
remember like every time we got there
like from the airport honey you're like
tired and you're carrying all your
luggage on my ha now you have to carry
like this big-ass suitcase up four
flights of stairs
oh man it's not like you're a
four-year-old how big was your suitcase
well my parents bought me the same the
small version of what they had so we
could look like a family but still look
huge cuz like back in those days when
you go visit your family you're visiting
for like a month or two you pack a [ __ ]
ton of [ __ ] I know one did like one week
trips the way they do now
so you're just dragging that [ __ ] up the
stairs all the way up and it was like
really really heavy on my damn I wish
you had an elevator I came here for ya
oh yeah really that's some normal stuff
me [ __ ] like chucky cheese would have
a elevator I feel like I'm a four year
old be like I wish I could fly ya had no
imagination at four I wouldn't even
remember that [ __ ] yo would you guys
complain if you were in the residents of
this building you can't even access this
[ __ ] ya know if they if he paid for an I
didn't pay for no no but you can't
access it she says yeah but I didn't pay
for it though why would I have the right
to access it okay I got complaints of
the building owner and be like hey make
it accessible to everyone
if I pay for it yeah if I even if you're
just living that I mean you are paying
your rent not me put if I didn't pay for
the elevator it's like me going I hate
my neighbor has a hot tub that he spend
like three g's on can I use it it's like
whoa I didn't really pay huntin he's
also not the average person really wait
why would people get mad because someone
paid for an elevator out of their own
pocket and there's no access so for me I
wouldn't get mad at that I would just be
like what the [ __ ] now we could build
whatever we want whenever like what's
next
that's what well whatever's next is
whoever has the wallet to make what
happened next but now your building
looks all [ __ ] crazy and then what if
like someone dies on it or something or
it affects you somehow like they care
about that in China that's all right
they don't get angry but like more like
selfish ass like that I guess like more
like well I I live on the fifth floor
why can't I use their you know way they
could make it right through six and then
just walk down to the fifth no there's
no entrance it goes straight to is unit
yeah yeah it opens up right in front of
his
that's pretty gangster yeah I don't know
if I would share that experience just
cuz like what you were saying like I
didn't pay so I can't that wouldn't
really be my more so of like people just
got booed on [ __ ] they want that's good
I guess for me it would be like well I
would want to talk to the building
manager and be like okay can we work
something out maybe you can charge us a
little bit extra in our rent I'm willing
to pay but I want to use the elevator
too so let's figure it out where we can
all benefit from this thing that's now
built when it comes to elevators though
I think I treat it like it's a car where
it can [ __ ] up so I would want someone
that's certified and professional it's
not like building drywall you know it's
like people are gonna use that every day
and that [ __ ] could snap or break or
whatever next story there was this woman
who lives in Colorado that she found her
car with a huge scratch on it
and then on her windshield there was an
apology note two $20 bills and half a
joint oh hey that's Wow broken a broken
wing windshield er no a scratch on her
car don't scratch oh [ __ ] everything
forty bucks is gonna take care of that
so this whole thing is the car and this
like a spray pump
I don't think 40 bucks is gonna cover
that though then the gale and half a
joint half was it like already smoke
yeah oh my god they're probably smoking
us oh [ __ ] my back yeah you look like a
girl wrote it so it says nice penmanship
hey I am very sorry truly I am sorry
I believe that says please forgive me
for the scratch man [ __ ] for this grin
like a frowny face and then 40 bucks and
then here's the half way so so they
wrote it on two separate No oh they were
high as [ __ ] what's the order of how I
do it uh-huh right this uh huh oh yeah
one more thing yeah
that's all I got jesse pinkman type move
oh [ __ ]
yo [ __ ] [ __ ] oh we have $40 [ __ ] yo he
just walks away
so that the part where they said sorry
for the scratch man that's an envelope
and so they put all this in the envelope
it's a little oh yeah the homeowner or
the car owner found the note and
everything is she was just saying that
she was just laughing so hard on her way
home that she just didn't know to think
of it that's awesome you smoke the weed
she says she's not a smoke girl that
she's a runner and she doesn't know what
she's gonna do with it that's the funny
part is how come they assumed who were
kind of smoked it's a half a maybe
they're like I know you gonna be pissed
here's a little something to chill you
out but it could have been like a
freaking devout Christian soccer mom
that doesn't drink or smoke or do
anything like you don't know who's this
news station they they put this in their
segment called the most Colorado thing
and so they're like today this is the
most Colorado thing so I don't know are
they saying like people in call are
really nice and then just donors
probably more the stoner
oh yeah I think that was a really cool
gesture I think I'd be the last pick I'd
be like man this sucks but this did take
a lot of effort I appreciate it how big
was the scratch I can't tell from the
picture
yeah they don't mention like the size or
anything and there's nothing else to
really it does look pretty bad though
well if it goes great throatily
yeah it's on our bumper it's half a
joint so this is like the whole bumper
[ __ ] we should Eve have a joint they
smoked half of it to like I don't know
what you have what if what if for them
they were like I'm really enjoying this
so I'm gonna sacrifice what I really
love and give that why don't they roll
up another joint for them nice one
they're just like oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
gross you guys are I found any anything
on your windshield before after being
hit or just for anything like
can you find a surprise in your
windshield ticket park in front of the
bay doors out here I find that all the
time oh yeah I mean I've had that or
I've had like people hitting on me or a
pad fans like right on my [ __ ] car
with the dust you should wash your car
that's that's funny take-home message
for sure yeah you know I just remember
going out to my car on the street and I
just see a dent in like the side of my
car cuz I think somebody was sitting on
it or leaning against it oh that sucks
yeah I don't like what the [ __ ] I
remember this here because I see I see a
lot of people being against like cars
are parked on the street oh that's rude
and I know that like if your dad push if
you push like into my car like you could
dent it so like I think they sat on it
and then it dented on the hood or on the
side it was like on the side of the hood
yeah oh you know I saw some hack online
where if you boil a pot of water and
then you pour it on your car will just
pop out yeah I also saw the baby
blow-drying or something like that -
blow drying it so heat makes it pop to
its original form yeah it's out now but
yeah when I came out I was like what the
[ __ ] is this you guys never got hit up
by those guys in the parking lot that
say that they'll fix your dent no oh
yeah I've gotten the wind chill guys
like windshield wiper guys that make it
worse than what it already
you mean the homeless people that steal
the squeegee from the gas station and
when you pull up they just start
squeezing it up and they're like cracked
out so they're not even looking at you
and they're doing it like are you sure
you do it four times thanks for watching
guys and those are our thoughts what are
your thoughts don't forget to comment
below we want to know what you guys are
thinking but don't write anything that
will make it sad or make us mad because
after all we're just kidding news and
we're a very happy channel for the last
video click up here
[Music]